All right,
welcome back to Computer Vision again.
We're going back to recognition now.
Remember, before we were talking
about supervised classification?
Supervised classification is I give you
a bunch of labeled examples, right?
Typically referred to
as training examples.
And you're supposed to come up with
a function that'll label some new
examples.
And we showed this one where, we have a
bunch of hand-drawn fours and hand-drawn
nines, and the idea was, given some new
input, is it a four or is it a nine?
The idea was,
since we know what the desired labels
are from the training data,
we're going to try to build a classifier
that's going to minimize the expected
misclassification, or minimize our risk.
All right, and we talked about
that there were two strategies.
One was called generative,
where we probabilistically model
each of the classes and then,
somehow, picked them, we'll talk
about those again just for a second.
And then there is this discriminative,
and discriminative says, I don't care so
much about modeling the classes,
what I care about is modelling some
sort of boundary between the classes.
And that makes it easier
to make some decisions.
So, we talked about the risk of
a particular decision as being,
if you're making a particular decision,
what's the probability that that
decision's wrong, and what's the cost
of making that wrong decision?
So, for example, let's suppose that I'm
going to label something as a four.
Well, if I'm going to
label it as a four,
what's the risk associated
with it being a four?
Well, that risk would be,
well, you know, what's the probability
that it's actually a nine, okay?
And what's the cost, to me,
of calling a nine a four, all right?
So that's the risk of labeling
something a four, right?
because it actually might have
been a nine, and what's the cost.
Likewise, suppose I'm going to
label something a nine.
What's the risk of
labeling something a nine?
Well the risk of labeling something
a nine is the probability that it was
actually a four, times the cost of
labeling something a four as a nine.
Right?
And, where should my
decision boundary be?
Well my decision boundary should be
that the risk of either decision would
be the same.
Okay, and that was the idea
of the generative model.
And so that's what's being shown here
is, so here are my, all my real fours so
I'm pretty sure that they're four,
so I'm going to call them fours.
But as I'm getting over to
the other side, it might be a nine.
Here are all my nines, and
as I'm getting closer over here,
it might be a four.
And this boundary in the middle,
that's where the risk is the same.